[Music]
guys battle stations right now turn the
couch
we got a VFX emergency
you know Peter get up here all right
welcome back to VFX artists react we're
having an emergency session right now
because you guys know we're about to
watch you know
[Music]
just very strange it's just very strange
it's like technically it's actually
totally fine it's just very strange but
we're not here to like dig into the
critiques of cats the Broadway musicals
Gandalf the cat and all the grey cat now
Gandalf the white cat just trying to get
some cheese
wait so some cats are wearing jackets
but other cats aren't wearing anything
and I can't tell his Judi Dench's jacket
her fur or is it a jacket is it dead cat
fur dead cat is it a dead cat is an
interesting question though so I think
it's important to note that almost no
one really knows much about this movie
so most of what we're saying here is
pure speculation according to the actors
who are on set they actually had
costumes and the only thing that they're
gonna be adding were like whiskers tails
and ears so one person's job is just the
tail Lord is adding tails to everyone so
most of the effects we are seeing right
now are actually unfinished they're at
but like the 80 to 90 percent finished
stage and honestly some of these shots
look really good
from a purely technical standpoint the
VFX are totally a-okay none of the
reactions here are
oh the lighting sucks oh this looks so
fake and a CG like it looks CG but like
it doesn't look like they made a mistake
in how it looks everybody's actually
reacting to what they should be reacting
to which is the decision to make human
animal hybrids they have human-animal
hybrids why are we debating whether the
earth is flat do they have human-animal
hybrids it's like the character itself
is freaking people out not the technical
achievement of it like Sonic it was the
character itself that was a little weird
looking they don't look right and a lot
of people have been attributing this to
the uncanny valley I'm getting some
uncanny valley for sure all of their
faces are covered in fur yeah the
entirety of their cheekbones and cheeks
it's all covered in fur and yet it still
retains a very human face like quality
judi dench for instance it looks like an
actual photography plate of her face on
a CG cat it almost looks like they like
cut out like the eyes and the nose and
the mouth and they're throwing me yeah
and the big stuck back onto the model it
definitely yeah
it definitely feels that way it's it's
well integrated and they're doing a fine
job of it but like that definitely lends
itself to a bit of this strange reaction
everybody's having because you're
getting just very raw like pieces of
human cut out and stuck on to this
character the weirdest always comes down
to the face but also the way she was
running up to that gate apparently they
all had to go to what's called like cat
school where they learn how to act like
cats I'm not kidding
so part of part of the weirdness comes
from there walking is not like a normal
walk they're all like humans acting like
cats
that's why do you think the whole movies
weird I just like I can't I'm not gonna
say movie not I am NOT disagreeing with
you there
Tom's pairing them with a kind of level
of technology which I don't think has
ever been used before so what I'm
gathering here is the jackets are real
the faces are kind of real and then the
body and that kinda stuff has basically
been replaced by fur and a CG body we've
used digital photo technology to create
the most perfect covering of fur they
did wear the costume and they did all
the choreography for real and I think
Taylor Swift even said there was no
motion capture which means they're
basically matching an actual animation
of a CG person to the real performances
on set okay that's me that's big door
big door that's a big door so the sets
are real from get it gathering for this
I assumed this sets would be real just
like the actual play they built like
oversized sets to make everybody feel
small they all have these headbands oh
yeah look at that there's a person in
the back on wearing motion tracking
markers so they definitely are having a
bunch of tracking markers on them so
that is absolutely a form of motion
capture if we get a glimpse of his
monitor there you can kind of see so
somebody is wearing a suit but I bet you
that's just for lighting reference
that's motion capture yeah that's motion
capture all right well it's definitely a
parent they're using a variety of
methods to capture the motion of the
choreography you know we're seeing
motion trackers but these days you need
what we've been doing with our xn
students you guys have to check out this
project we did Sam built a video game we
can control it with a motion capture
suit it was the previous video to this
one so check it out if you haven't seen
it yet because the showcase is a really
interesting piece of technology which
also kind of calls into question why
they wouldn't just have actors wear one
of those if they're going to replace
them anyways
these are people but they're cats and
this is kind of blowing my mind
they've erased the person a hundred
percent now it's a complete CG character
it's just written up
it's a weird monster is when you're
watching weird monsters dance around on
screen oh I feel like it'd be more
valuable to have people in costumes but
there's still the person there yeah all
the reactions here have nothing to do
with the technical execution this isn't
about the visual effects is about the
art direction but that's part of the
overall visual effects umbrella art
direction is certainly part of it this
trailer is like glass blowing art like
what who who nobody asked for this
that's the thing it's the worst musical
of all time it's not a very good musical
that's for sure we're cats are wonky
here's a song about a cat do do it do do
do and then it's the same thing for two
hours hey you know what that movie good
for you I'll probably check it out it
also like glassblowing art it's like the
worst oblong marble who wants a spin
marble like I don't want that what's
this blade you croissant-doughnut thing
let's jump into our patron decided see
we do a scene where patrons get to vote
and this is the winner
[Music]
you know it's kind of crazy to think
that like there is all this hubbub of
about twenty twelve million of the world
I was so long ago that like totally
forgot about it it's so good really good
roland emmerich right the same guy that
didn't pendants say he's the master of
world ending stuff look at a good that
looks
we know the plants moving all the
physics on all that so many paul just
one tree is like you enough to crash my
computer a crazy thing here's like bring
all of it together it's nuts lady just
got how much of this deep think is
actually practical except for the mud i
think this is a hundred percent
computer-generated this is a full
animation and they did this back in 2009
[Applause]
watch out John Cusack
the building's clapping oh there I've
never seen a building collapse off this
plate I've never seen a building
collapse and look as good as it in this
because I don't think any movies got
that structural slow everything falling
apart five oh it's a good one
there goes trees they got all the same
is that the same golf course Harrison
Ford crashed in oh in real life he
crashed there yeah not for a movie yeah
oh wow that is cool what whoever wrote
this seems like yeah look at all this
it's so much physics objects like just
having that many objects is hard for a
computer let alone physically simulating
all of it on top of like the smoke and
the dust and the plants waving in the
wind oh the Train I love the Train
coming out flying under it I mean they
could pull up by this point but that
wouldn't be any fun man what what a
sequence all of this stuff going on are
is simulated the the buildings
collapsing the street and Road coming up
the grass caving into itself it's not
like a person going in and moving every
single brick right they know that they
want a bridge to collapse right it's
like a hit play and let it simulate and
then you let the physics do its job but
a person has to animate and all these
events to start and stop at certain
points essentially they're doing like
the macro view the the amount of
computing power to do this shot alone
like I can't even comprehend there's a
lot of technology that you now see in
every film that was kind of this film
was kind of the first one to do it
so this shot right here blows my mind
obviously you have a bunch of physics
and stuff going on
the reason this blows my mind is because
it's bringing everything together in the
visual effects world at that time at the
height of its full potential into one
shot you're seeing a bunch of different
software and a bunch of different
programs being brought together for a
single shot and likely a bunch of things
being rendered out in different places
and that mastery of bringing all these
things together is where rolls like a
visual effects supervisor comes in handy
because you need that that director that
coordinator to make all this software
talk to each other and make sure all
these pieces line up like just a plant
alone with leaves looking realistic and
moving in the wind it's hard for a
computer to do
there are hundreds of palm trees
hundreds of plants in the shot there are
yards with grass a house collapsing is
hard to do there are like 20 houses
collapsing in the shot not to mention
the street falling apart the car is
falling into it the dust the smoke all
that stuff it's just it's a masterwork
of things coming together I think we
really cool to talk a little bit about
how you actually achieve some of these
physics and how like you could even
achieve some of these physics now the
physics engine they use in this movie is
called bullet physics that's doesn't
mean it's physics for bullets if that's
just the name of the physics engine
bullet physics is actually an open
source physics engine and one of the
things that bullet physics does that
other physics engines didn't do at the
time was a kind of internal friction so
what I mean by that is let's say you
have a stack of blocks on wooden blocks
now the wooden block on the bottom of
that stack is under the weight of that
full stack meaning it's going to have
more friction because it's under all
that pressure you need this internal
friction to have large structures
collapse accordingly because large
structures have weight and pressure
inside of them so this is a great
demonstration of bullet physics this is
is it effectively exactly what's
happening in 2012 except those little
wooden blocks are being replaced with
like concrete and glass right there you
see how it didn't collapse because the
internal pressure and internal friction
of the blocks sitting on top of each
other is keeping the blocks of the
inside from being affected that's
something that only bullet physics could
do back in the day so this here's
physics and notice that when the ball
goes to the top the bottom Amelie kicks
out of this tower and that's because
you're knocking the eternal friction
that bullet physics is giving the moment
one object in that tower gets motion
that motion translates to everything and
something the bottom blows out and the
whole thing falls over and it's not
stable if your physics simulation isn't
accurate we can still pick up on the
pulse motion but here the motion is very
true to real life it looks very real we
looked at 2012 and that was because you
guys chose it on patreon so thank you
for voting there and you can become a
patron and vote for the next one - link
in the description below
[Music]
ooh Jonathan wick Johnny wick
Jonathan wiggle I think they're gonna
try to hurt John wick but John wick
don't take no guff who's that can't tell
who it is there's a shadow on his face
could it be the same guy who was again
in the shower
Oh
bad guy
pretty smart John wick a little bit
smarter he'll be smart but also it's
just like not discount that Keanu's
heart rate is probably not exceeding 80
in fact it goes down gotta reads lowest
resting heart rate is when he's fighting
cuz that's when he's the most relaxed
dead dead everybody's dead so you might
wonder what we reacting to in this shot
the muzzle flashes it's a cool movie and
I love these fight scenes with the
muzzle flashes they're just a little
disappointing in motion they look fine I
actually think in motion they could look
even better there's one thing that we're
particularly good at here at corridor
it's muzzle flashes muzzle flashes we've
been doing like 20 years a long time
perfecting our muzzle flashes because
there's certain physics with muzzle
flashes work and they don't quite adhere
to it for John wick so these aren't real
guns obviously you're not going to shoot
real guns but blank-firing guns are
frequently used in productions we
actually got to use blank firing guns
for our battlefield series blank firing
guns are deadly they are basically real
guns if Brandon Lee from The Crow he was
killed by a blank firing gun actually
multiple people have been killed by
blank firing guns on set you're not
going to be able to use blank firing
guns in a situation like this it's just
it's too dangerous they're probably
using airsoft guns Gaspar airsoft guns
so some things that you merely notice is
you have the muzzle flash that muzzle
flash puts light into the scene and
muzzle flashes are actually pretty
bright do the lights not bad they're
adding more light the scene basically
it's painting it in by hand you can see
it on the front of counter reads you can
see out in front of that stuntman the
Bloods looking a little weird but it's
just for one frame so sushi not that big
of a deal but there's an immediate flaw
that stands out to me muzzle flashes
don't exist for two frames they also
especially do not go backwards into the
gun you shoot the gun the Gunpowder in
the shell expands the gun powder turns
basically into expanding gas in the
initial stage that gas is glowing and
that's the flesh that's the fire so
you'll sometimes capture no muzzle flash
sometimes they'll catch for the tail end
of the muzzle flash in fact it depends
entirely on your cameras most cameras
these days have rolling shutters which
means that it's scanning from top to
bottom and a truly real muzzle flash
sometimes only captured halfway so this
is a real m249 shooting real blanks
alright so that's a real muzzle flash
notice how bright it is in the scene
around it that generally did a good job
of that with John wick it's brightening
his face it's
reflection in his goggles it's also huge
also notice that we're only capturing
the top half of it this star is not
coming out at the bottom because of the
rolling shutter now notice on the ground
below it it's kicking up dust on the
ground that's an actual shockwave from
the front of the gun and that's not a
fake camera shake that's going ah thank
you for the gun hahaha the next issue is
the smoke there's no smoke you wanna
know how to give a gun power you show
the power with thick ejecting gases you
show it with a smoke the smoke is just
the cooled gases that the muzzle flash
was made out of so if those hot gases in
one frame expanded to this big and in
the next frame now that's just smoke and
they're the same size that makes zero
sense for the physics of the scene now
notice the smoke coming out this gun is
as big as the muzzle flash the general
rule of thumb is if in one frame you've
gone from here to here how far did you
go in the next frame from the same
distance from here to here so if your
muzzle flashes this big and the next
frame the gasses should be this big the
size of the smoke coming out these guns
should be leaps and bounds bigger than
what you're seeing in these shots and
that expansion of the smoke and that
fast puffs that comes out of the gun
gives that impression of that punch and
of that projectile that's rocketing out
of that going out like Mach one and they
don't have that in John wick here once
you drop in the smoke at the right scale
at the right speed suddenly your guns
he's powerful but you know what I would
like to see what John wick would look
like with actual realistic muzzle
flashes and I think we could fix the
muzzle flashes in John wick so if you
guys remember how we fixed the Scorpion
King I would love to try fixing the
muzzle flashes in John wick so if you'd
like to see us try fixing the muzzle
flashes from John wick and a couple
other movies too subscribe to the
channel it's gonna be coming real soon I
like John wick a lot I'd love to see it
accurate too real guns if you've seen
any movies or TV shows that you want us
to look at yours TV shoes yeah that's it
if you've seen any TV shoes and goddang
it
if you've seen any movies or TV shows
with visual effects that you want us to
look at leave a comment down below who
knows we might just get to in the next
one